it's uh it's good times they've built
their own wall they uh rely
on the cops to protect them they got 205
swag bags they they're a hundred percent
in touch with the american people
in touch mainly because they wish to
push you away with their hand that's the
amount of the touching that goes on it's
just
their hand on your head pushing you away
a few quick notes
on the oscars so it is perfectly clear
at this point that hollywood despises
its own audience
despises it so every so often they will
make you you know 100 million dollar
movie
and that's the one that they give to you
and then there are the ones they do for
them
and the ones they do for them those are
all the ones that are featured at the
oscars
you know movies like nomad land about
elderly white people pooping in buckets
or the father about anthony hopkins
struggling with dementia
movies like like the movie about fred
hampton
whose name escapes me at the moment
about how the black panthers were going
to be the saviors
of the united states or the other movie
about how black panthers were going to
be the saviors of the united states
written by aaron sorkin
or maybe it's the borat movie which is
actually actively unfunny
militantly unfunny but pushes all the
right buttons
for folks in media land or maybe you're
just super
into all of the other movies that nobody
has ever seen that were nominated this
year
it used to be that the oscars would
nominate for best picture you know
movies the people that actually see
i'm old enough to remember when the dark
knight got a best picture nomination
and when return of the king one best
picture no movies people had actually
seen
and now hollywood only rewards movies
that no one has seen because they
actively hate their audience they think
americans are fools they think americans
are dumb asses
they think that they can basically make
money off of you by popping a marvel
movie out once in a while and then they
use that money to make the movies that
really make them feel artistic
and all of those movies of course are
critiques of the evils of america
all those movies are critiques of
america's health care system
like that the one about the drummer who
goes deaf right which is really a
critique of america's terrible horrible
no good very bad health care system
or the or the movie about how difficult
it is to be
an asian-american immigrant in the
united states menari about the
difficulties of the american dream
right every movie is this every single
movie that was nominated this year
is essentially about the evils of the
united states in one way or another
because that's what they think of you
it's not even what they think of the
system that's what they think of their
own audience
hollywood despises its own audience and
they are living in a bubble where they
get to live off the fruit of the land
or they never have to see the
consequences of their own policies where
they get to live the high life and and
that's what the oscars represent
is how in a bubble these folks are i
mean truly insanely in a bubble
how big is that bubble well for example
according to the post-millennial there
were walls
actively erected outside the academy
awards to protect the hollywood elite
quote security fencing was erected
around the perimeter of union station in
downtown l.a on sunday to provide
protection for the hollywood elite and
their academy award ceremony the red
carpet the dazzling celebs who walked
were well secured from the general
public
union station was cordoned off with
fencing the entrances were also blocked
with security guards and additional
measures
now typically union station is you know
a station
it is like a train station in la so i
don't know why they couldn't hold this
thing at the kodak theater every major
venue in l.a
has been empty for literally a year at
this point instead they decided you know
what we're going to displace all of
these homeless people that we welcomed
into our city to help wreck the quality
of life for people who actually pay
taxes
and live in homes and then we're going
to make all those people move out of
union station
just like we would in malibu the
post-millennial reported union station
is typically home to a high population
of homeless yet the city of l.a forced
those city dwellers to move
from their temporary digs in order to
make room for the oscars the city moved
the homeless under the alleged threat of
destroying their belongings if they fail
to comply which is weird because they
won't do that if a homeless person
plunks down their tent directly
on the sidewalk outside of your home the
city won't move it but if you get in the
way
of francis mcdormand winning her third
oscar
you are out gang police also amply
protected the celebs who stood on stage
in designer gowns and suits to decry
american law enforcement
on tole heals and with resounding voices
actors and artists used their platform
to speak against the very institution
that was protecting them
from the greater homelessness of l.a of
those who spoke about the cops only
tyler perry said i refuse to hate
someone for being a police officer
so it's a it's good times they've built
their own wall
apparently they uh rely on the cops to
protect them
really solid stuff there from your
hollywood brethren who
know better than you they are just
better people than you by the way how
much better
well at least two hundred and five
thousand dollars better because they got
205 000
swag bags according to forbes.com
every year celebrity and product
placement marketing company distinctive
assets put together a gift bag the 25
nominees for best actor actress and
director
take home with them whether they win or
not every one of this year's swag bags
is valued at around 205
000 205 remember we're supposed to be in
the middle of a great depression right
now in which millions of people were
thrown out of work by a giant pandemic
very important that the people who are
already rich and famous
are given 205 000 swag bags
that is a dip in value of 20 000 from
last year
the academy which is putting on its 93rd
oscars this year complained about the
less than wholesome nature of some of
the gifts and the negative press
surrounding it after last year this
year's gift bag reflects the twin events
overshadowing the ceremony
calls for social justice in the wake of
george floyd's murder and the outbreak
of coven 19.
distinctive assets 49 year old founder
ferry said quote
we did want the bags to feel like they
had a bigger purpose than just here's a
bag full of free stuff
some of the bags we've been doing have
been from female owned businesses black
owned businesses disabled entrepreneurs
and companies who give back
even ones you wouldn't necessarily think
give back
apparently just filled with wonderful
wonderful stuff
several of the gifts promote health and
well-being like a medical grade mask
from 99 guard
iv on call concierge vitamin intravenous
infusions to bolster immunity or to
recover from a hangover
c60 purple power antioxidant and violet
breast health supplements
but there are also some lavish things
like for example a twelve thousand
dollar four night stay for two at the
golden door a southern california spa
also you can get retreat for a three
night stay at the potter nostra
lighthouse on the island
of homniskar on the west coast of sweden
so good stuff the gift bag also includes
a 24 karat gold vape cartridges from
hollow tips and sleep capsules that
blend
cbd with low dose melatonin and hemp
cell from fifth element for post
workout recovery really amazing stuff in
this in the swag bag these are these are
folks who are definitely
they they're 100 in touch with the
american people
in touch mainly because they wish to
push you away with their hand that's the
amount of the touching that goes on it's
just
their hand on your head pushing you away
that's those are the folks in hollywood
by the way
americans know it new poll out from the
daily wear today two-thirds of americans
have not seen
a single film nominated for best picture
by the way that is a lie for sure it's
more like
9 10 so people have not seen a single
film nominated for best picture if they
have seen any of the films nominated for
best picture it's probably just borat
right
because board was on netflix so people
tuned into that for 10 minutes before
tuning out
71 percent of americans said award
winners shouldn't give political
speeches
most americans don't think the oscars
are too white despite reporting on the
topic
55 percent of americans correctly say
that conservative films and actors would
not have a fair shot at winning an oscar
and what are the most anticipated films
for 2021 the new james bond and top gun
movies namely the ones that hollywood
makes to hate but no they have to make
in
order to pay the bills for movies that
nobody ever ever wants to see
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video